the 72nd primetime emmy awards will be
airing on sunday september 20th on abc
hosted by jimmy kimmel and here to talk
with me about this
first of its kind ceremony is our
variety reporter
angelique jackson hi and our
senior writer from the hollywood
reporter mikey o'connell hey mikey
yes thank you both so much for joining
me
it's such a thrill to have two fellow tv
lovers
kicking this off um first off happy pre
emmys angelique how are you feeling
about this year
i am excited a little sad i mean
obviously we can join each other in the
virtual press room
but i'm really just wondering what i
need to wear should i wear a ball gown
or should i chill out
i'm good i'm excited to not be there or
in a virtual press room i'm just gonna
watch on television
for once well we are going virtual
this year uh the executive producers of
the emmys including
jimmy kimmel have sent out letters to
all of the nominees
letting them know that they are going to
be sending in high quality cameras
into their homes that means of course
this year there is no red carpet there
is
no audience and they're looking to go
live from
140 locations when you guys hear that
just right off the bat what do you think
is going to be the biggest
challenge this year i'm just imagining
the video village
with 140 monitors of
just like every actor and producer's
home or or kitchen or front yard i just
see
the the biggest issue
is is one that we're not going to see
it's it's technology like
this is like
the most elaborate like sports event
ever
it's like they're throwing the olympics
like it's the amount of different feeds
in play
are just wild like i don't even
understand how these things work so i
don't really know
how to talk about it but i do know that
it is an overwhelming
amount of logistics definitely and i
love that you brought up sports because
jimmy kimmel is actually going to be
broadcast live but this year it is from
the staples center
and the executive producers have said
that they chose to do that because
number one
so much bigger than the microsoft center
across the street and number two they
are used to
being able to beam out these games
worldwide um
angelique what do you think it's going
to take this year to make this virtual
emmys a success
well like mikey sadden like you said i
mean the logistics of the technology of
it are the biggest
the biggest hurdle i would say i mean
the biggest help that they have is that
they have jimmy kimmel as a host
who we know from his show and then of
course from hosting the oscars and so
many award shows
is the king of this live tv format so
he'll be able to keep it moving
you know coming from his central point
on stage but
i think you know when we were talking
about that that question of like
how are they gonna do this the idea that
the producers are not gonna know who the
winners are
beforehand is insane the fact that they
can't like pre-predict okay you know the
technical director is gonna press this
button and he's gonna do this so we can
make sure we cut to the right person
that is gonna be wild and i do not i
i wish them all the best luck in the
world but it's gonna also probably be
really cool
i think it's gonna be really cool but i
love the fact that you brought up that
the executive producers do not know the
winners this year because they actually
asked the television academy if just
this once
they could get the winners ahead of time
and the television academy said
nope sorry not happening um but one
thing that i am excited that the eps
have said is that they are going to show
us some of that behind the scenes
magic some of that controlled chaos
that's going on
um how does that make you feel knowing
that we are going to get a peek behind
this crazy curtain mikey
i mean i'm psyched i i was talking to
reggie hello the other day who's one of
the executive producers of the show
and there's just such a
like invigorated spirit
among the people working on it this year
because i mean you can say that you're
going to play with a format and do
something different
and like every year award shows are the
same
and this is the first time that they
really just have the chance to just like
burn it to the ground and like do
something completely different and
whether it's uh if it goes off
flawlessly
or whether it's full of mistakes it's
gonna be live it's gonna be exciting and
and i think that people are just gonna
really hopefully
tune in for that sort of like communal
aspect of it because there's sort of a
camaraderie to it
one of the biggest changes of this year
is that because there is no red carpet
we are not going to necessarily see
all of our favorite stars in one place
all glammed up and in fact the eps
sent out a letter to all the nominees
saying that the dress code this year is
come as you are but make an effort
uh mikey how do you interpret that what
do you think that means for our group
i think that it's obviously like
no one's gonna do a sincere
ball gown like if we see someone going
over the top i
imagine it's going to be for hugh's sake
i think especially like in the comedy
fields you're going to see
a lot of people getting playful with it
but
i mean it's just it's it's not going to
be as formal as it was before but i
i think the the fashion the sartorial
surprises
uh will be will be worth tuning in for
alone
i think we will see a lot of like
sweatpants attire
you know cute on the top you know you
know the normal zoom
look um but i don't know i have a
feeling like
and not just me but somebody else will
probably wear some sort of gown just
because why not
if you if you are in the air
conditioning for once why not lounge
around in your gown
well guys as we know jimmy kimmel is of
course our host this year he's going to
be taking the helm of this
virtual ship mikey do you think
that he's going to be able to do it
justice
yes i there's honestly like no one else
i would
rather navigate these
sort of strange waters
he's really good at this he's
he he's great on his own show he's great
at the emmys he's great at the oscars i
think he
knows what he's doing and i think that
he can pivot in
in a way that we may end up needing
someone to pivot if things go awry
with 140 i think it helps when you have
a host who does have that level of
knowledge experience and respect in the
industry and
also knows how to navigate a tricky and
sometimes
you know when things get negative
[Music]
situations
you